hi everyone it's jerry here's a fun end
game study composed by a kramer that was
published in 1922.
it's white to move if you'd like to go
ahead pause the video
see if you can find the best
continuation for white
okay the solution to this one
is one that draws our attention to tempe
or timing in chess
the correct first move is king f6
g4
we cannot catch this pawn we must try
something clever
king g6
g3 no matter
or whether it's g3 or king g8 we follow
up in the same way
h7
black with this last move cannot move
their king
g2 is the only move and now just before
black promotes we sneak our king into
this pocket on h6
and now unfortunately no matter what
black does or no matter what black
promotes to on his next turn
it will be a draw
due to stalemate
if it's a queen or a rook
or a draw due to
insufficient material promoting to a
minor piece
again timing is the key with this one
doing something other than king f6
such as king g6 the timing will be off
because at the end of this one
black would be promoting
in this case with check
king f6 is the correct start and then
sneaking over to h6 which again is
resulting in this case
as a draw by stalemate or insufficient
material
so feel free to share how you did with
this one and as always i hope you got
something out of it take care bye
you